look when you're playing at the highest
level of competition
mistakes happen but sometimes it's not a
tactical error that screws you over
whether your wrist twitched and your
mouse moved or you fat fingered a key
and moved in the wrong direction
those kinds of mistakes can be
unforgettable
one misclick can be the difference
between a player's name going down in
the history books
or going down as a meme and sometimes
both happen at the same time for the
same reason
here are the top 10 misclicks in esports
miss clicking us into this video at
number 10 is insania
picture this it's an illumination match
at ti between alliance and
rng and alliance are looking to ban out
gyrocopter that's
ban not pick pretty big difference right
i will say if i'm a storm i'd love to be
in a situation where i'm against the
lash
as they're gonna take the gyrocopter for
themselves so this is gonna be an
offlane boy
that is true something that we
definitely did not
expect rng couldn't believe their luck
insania's misclick now meant that
alliance had to fight an uphill battle
with a comp they never
actually wanted
are you serious whatever did this just
happen
it's fine we gotta deal with it oh my
god
okay uh sorry guys how about offline
let's see what they pick okay let's see
what they pick don't pick your heroes
don't worry don't worry we got this
alliance put up a good fight but when
they eventually lost insania was left
wondering if
his misclick cost his team a
multi-million dollar payday
43 minutes into the game we have
ourselves a match where
both sides really they had their chance
right uh they had their game plans
things started to come online
obviously the disappointment here for
alliance
moving on to number nine we have ky xyz
aegis denial
it's ti3 it's an elimination match and
orange just need to grab the aegis to
win
should be on the hands of pushy and back
goes the hands of windrunner
yeah no what they denied it they failed
oh oh we see a lot of rares being in and
out
for witnessing the denial of venegas
that's not really what you want to do
ky xy
they are not too happy right now this
myth click to end
all miss clicks actually destroyed the
aegis before kyxy could pick it up
that's a tilter so much so that orange
went on to lose the game despite having
a huge
lead at that
and moment navi
they come back from what looked like
oblivion
to get into their third international
grand
final these days if you make that kind
of mistaken dota
your teammates will be quick to say that
they've been kyx wide
it's the miss click that just keeps on
giving
culling our way into number 8 is wild
turtle
way back in summer 2014 tsm were up
against dignitas in a best of five
after dig took game one tsm's backs were
against the wall in game two which had
developed into an
hour-long slug fest with 65 minutes on
the clock and two of his tsm teammates
dead
wild turtle went for the backdoor win
all he had to do was
right-click the nexus he's making his
way in
oh my gosh he's gonna say zion spartan
you just did this to my team
now it's my turn guess who's back shots
it's
[Applause]
oh my god they kill him the nexus is
saved
65 minutes and the game continues dyrus
tries to get himself in
he's got tiny arms though and he can't
get to the nexus in time
saplings won't be able to do it he
misses and dignitas
saves the day with the entire team why
in the world
would wild turtle use culling when it's
a hit away from winning the game on the
nexus
lucian's ultimate the culling does no
damage to the enemy nexus and it was
just a couple of auto attacks away from
crumbling
luckily for wild turtle tsm managed to
close the game out shortly after
otherwise this would have been much
higher on our list
that's it nobody's got it no one's got
it ladies and gentlemen
game number three one to one tsm wins
game number two
[Applause]
at number seven we have a rage quit from
injury that could have easily been
avoided
i mean i hate to say it but i think idra
may have left the game that he had won
idra is a starcraft legend known for his
skill at the game
and for rage quitting games just a bit
too soon in a 2011 mlg pro circuit game
intra's opponent mma
accidentally destroyed one of his own
command centers yeah and
uh where did that medevac go i'm not
sure he's taking out the
oh my
goodness mma
[Applause]
oh the casters knew it was a mistake and
the fans did too but idra had no
idea it happened without this knowledge
indra took a bad fight
and presumed he didn't have enough left
to win the game now streaming forward
with circling mutas everything is
overrunning the sports by mma
wait what
[Music]
what
mma's huge misclick went completely
unpunished
and i can only imagine idre was even
more angry when he found out
next up at number 6 is one of the worst
misclicks you can make in league of
legends
picking teemo maybe one day the yordle
from hell will be a good pick in pro
play but that's never been the case
before
including the time that kramer
accidentally locked him in during a pro
match
shy change okay uh
they messed that one up by the little
face right there
oh no oh no that is uh not the look of
someone who's happy with the draft
that's just happened well i'm just like
hey
is like all right boys got this one in
the bag free game
kramer didn't have to pay for his
mistake the unwanted teemo was thrust
onto the shy and top lane and
while he didn't int he certainly didn't
help the nexus turrets
are falling it looks like longzhu are
going to be able to close this one out
at 33 and a half minutes
cj accidentally drafting the teemo
condemn them from the start and they
just couldn't find a foothold
in this game next exposed down a half hp
it's gonna fall as long as you come out
with a 2-0 victory
bodhi is a famous runescape streamer
known for his hardcore ironman accounts
one death and it's all over and in july
2020 he'd gone nine whole months without
dying but
bodhi's luck was about to run out his
demise didn't come from a dragon or a pk
he made the fatal error of going to the
bathroom
yo mr nine five nine eight zero eleven
two three five eight one three two one
three four five five two three five
seven one one thank you dude for the
prime i appreciate that
bodhi returned from his bowel movement
to find that a single mistake had ended
nine months of dedication holy [ __ ] i
actually died going afk
oh what a horrible way to go bro
moving on to number four we have easy
firing a blank
he saw him go by he missed his
opportunity right and i still said well
it doesn't matter anyway he can still be
guaranteed to have bragg and he fires
off a random bullet
and i am kind of beat 2017 north had
their backs against the wall versus
immortals
easy was defending aside and silently
waiting for the right shot
this is clever from cajun leaving easy
to make a destructive potential just
hold up towards stables as soon as he
plants ace he can stay there
and kill the rotating player i don't
think f1x will be checking on this
left-hand side az always guaranteed this
kill
oh what's him looking away
what's he done why has he done that why
did he pull the trigger
the casters were still confused when
they went to watch the replay
when in doubt always blame it on a
misclick
so here is where you said he saw him and
he did it and then he turned back
doesn't
and there's the shot it doesn't make any
sense to fire a bullet there
coming in at number three we have the
most heartbreaking own goal from sikki
absolute heartbreaker one they will not
be thinking about they will not forget
for a long time they will hopefully
they'll stop thinking about it
in four years or something my goodness
veloce and renegades were facing off in
overtime and if renegades lost this
they were going home storing a goal into
your own net is a bad idea at any time
but when sikki did it
it was heartbreaking back down sick he
puts it away cassio could win the game
but kami has him blocked
and now back in front of the box towards
the
bottom
you're kidding absolute tragedy for
renegades
torsos taking his time he knew
he had all the time in the world to get
up to it
and his teammate panics and just smashes
it into their own goal
tragedy is the perfect word to describe
that
you have got to be kidding me you think
that's sad
wait until you watch the video they made
about this historic moment
talk about a tear jerker
[Music]
coming in at number two it's summit1gs
1g
oh summit what's up reddit
you had it arya
summing in first place at the dreamhack
zowie open things were actually going
pretty well for summit all he had to do
was kill the last player and defuse the
bomb
first part went pretty well but then he
fat fingered his w
key and walked right into a molly losing
the round
and now it's summit in the 1v1 to try
and close this out against fugly
buggy playing it aggressively we know
that it's going to clutch it
and splice will close out map number one
16-11 oh wait
no what happened
oh no summit no
that blunder didn't just cause spliced
around either clg
forced it into overtime after that and
one eliminating splice from the
tournament
i think that's a double burn and with
that said clg
for the heartbreaking upset coming in
summit had control of the map but
unfortunately that mistake cost him big
time and clg will steal it away
and finally we are heading back to ti3
once again for our number one entry
shox's boar stun the setup was there
he's got to be kicking himself right now
that's
that one hurts with rattlesnake
retreating quantic
shocks that lined up the perfect flank
all he had to do was make sure his storm
hammer stunned pretty much
any enemy just not the boar now a
buyback from the darks here
they know aegis is down and they want to
take a fight now ben is going to cut
them off on the back line god's strength
and where's the storm hammer
four seconds now maybe only the other
way but you just won my man
i see gets sent up back back fall down
on top of everything
ice is gonna get burst down lulu's on
the run but he's fighting his way out of
this one trying to kill
everybody he might kill goat like he
does crystalline and getting some help
funds he's gonna get yet another kill
kabu my man gets a double on cm
he ain't done yet he's hunting for mad
now effie man is gonna be able to escape
he's stunned before
oh if you're a rattlesnake fan
or rather a quantic fan he had a two
hero stun
the setup was there he's gotta be
kicking himself right now
that's that one hurts this misclick
lost quantic the game but it did earn
shocks of the title of the boar
destroyer
which as far as silver linings for
misclips go is pretty badass
alright folks that's our list and i want
to make sure that you don't miss click
right now the right place to click at
this very moment is on the subscribe
button because we are on the way to 2
million subscribers and every click
helps
alright thanks so much for watching and
we'll see you next week
you're still here you're a dedicated fan
i love you good work
you you clicked on the subscribe button
you click on that bell now you do that
for me because i'm your best friend
you and i we're best friends now and
you're gonna click on the bell for me
after you click on the subscribe button
did you do it good job proud of you